this was an article that was sent by a
fella on temporary marriages making more
sense than marriage for life
and believe it or not there are actually
um
tribes and
um native like uh indigenous peoples
let's say
where it's quite common to have
temporary unions
um
and that makes sense i guess for
different reasons and i've said for a
while dudes that um
you know
the pro see
the thing with the whole marriage you
know situation is it's the only contract
that i'm aware of
and you guys correct me if i'm wrong i
mean you know the chat's open for you
guys but it's the only contract that i
can think of where
the other party is rewarded
richly for breaking it and is in fact
not only rewarded richly but is in many
cases incentivized
to break said contract
in my book i have a chapter on why smart
men don't marry
if you haven't seen it yet grab it on
amazon it's on kindle print and audible
i narrated it myself
and um there is a uh a segment actually
let me see if i can grab it real quick
and i'll read it to you uh but there's a
segment in there that i took right out
of a
discussion point with um
one of uh
my comments uh where is it smart man
don't marry i think it's in this chapter
over here
there it is 178.
man
i've gone through the
audiobook
um quite a few times now
and i need to fix a few things in it but
i haven't actually read
the print copy yet so it's kind of cool
to go through these
where is it in here
i know i copied it
in oh you know what i might have put
another chapter it's going to take me a
while to dig it up but basically what
the um
what the distilled version was
was um there was a woman that was having
a conversation with a co-worker and she
was married
and they were comparing notes you know
as women do they they often like to you
know hey what's your life like barbara
well becky let me tell you all about it
sort of thing
and um you know they were sort of sizing
up what their uh financial lives were
like so one's married they're both
working and the other one is uh single
as a single mom
and the single mom in the state that she
was located in was actually earning more
than the
they actually created this hilarious
uh acronym dinks double income no kids
you know it was where it started but
then obviously you know people started
getting divorced um you know with kids
but
they were comparing these notes and the
and the divorce lady with kids earning
like exact same job like both these
ladies were doing the exact same job so
they were earning the same income the
divorce lady getting assistance from the
government and from her ex was earning
more than the married couple
so there's an actual incentive to leave
a family union and break up the
household
take the kids have them the vast
majority of the time and you will be
richly rewarded you will be paid more at
the end of the day is what um was
discovered and i break down the details
in the book so you'd have to go through
it i'm sure some of you watching know
exactly what i'm talking about
but um yeah that was a big eye opener
and i've often said that you know things
like marriage
because you get rewarded for breaking
that contract and it's in many cases
depending on where you live you're
incentivized to do so
and you're in fact and you're
incentivized to do so in such a way that
it actually
harms
the father of your kids
pretty drastically if we're being honest
there's not a lot of guys that recover i
had a conversation this afternoon with a
bunch of guys in my group and
generally speaking if
if you're well off to begin within your
smart guy most guys after divorce end up
with far more money once they like just
cut
untie the knot cut the ties and pay with
you know pay their dues they they
generally end up with far more money but
not everybody can you know achieve that
level of success so it's not um
something everybody can achieve again
there's a lot of guys i know that that
like go right down the rabbit hole of
i'm never dealing with women again
you know i've learned my lesson you know
hands are burned and i'm i'm in the camp
where it's like look you know
like women are awesome they're fun but
um i wouldn't recommend anybody to live
in such a way that the state would view
as a marriage so if you're gonna do
anything like that make sure you have a
cohabitation agreement or some sort of
legal contract governing yourself
in case it has to untie which it you
know generally does
um
so let me read you this article here on
temporary marriages because i've often
said that i think that um
these sorts of things should be like a
car lease you know
you get together and you have maybe like
a five year lease you know this is like
a western thing obviously so
you know when i say western i'm talking
like western cowboy but like a western
thing like in the west
where
if you have to sign a contract a
marriage contract it's something like a
five-year lease so if it doesn't work
out at the end of the five years you can
just drop off the vehicle no further
obligations as long as there's no dents
in the door or anything like that
there's no scratches you have to deal
with or what do they call it excessive
wear and tear if you ever release a
vehicle
and then you just kind of move on to the
next vehicle
so
let me throw this up on the screen and
we'll hop into this um
yeah jerry says i think they're all
temporary and they all all they all are
to some degree
um why is my
bubble they're that's what i'm looking
for that's the one that i like
um
they are all things always are temporary
some degree you know they always
they always say that it's she's not
yours it's just your turn right
uh so
it's funny they picked these two for the
cover photo
if there's one guy that shouldn't have
not married this crazy chick it's it's
definitely brad pitt uh speaking of
crazy i've got a um i've got a ghosting
after this which which is like biblical
levels uh and there's a lesson in it too
so we'll get to that next um this is a
little bit of an older one it says
temporary marriage makes more sense than
a marriage for life most marriages end
in resentment and why should longevity
be the sole marker of a successful
marriage so this isn't a very long
article it's actually pretty short
in november 1891 the british sexologist
have locked ellis married the writer and
lesbian edith lees
he was 32 and a virgin and since he was
impotent they never consummated their
union after the honeymoon the two lived
separately in what he called an open
marriage the union lashed until lee's
death in 1916.
this is not what most would consider a
model marriage but perhaps because of
its
unusualness ellis was able to introduce
the idea that remains as radical and
tantalizing today as it was in his time
trial marriages in which he envisioned
couples exploring a temporary union of
varying levels of commitment that
allowed him to have sex access birth
control and have an easy divorce if
desired as long as no children were
involved that's where stuff gets
complicated right
um you know for the most part you can
just untie the knot give her half your
stuff
like if you've been married long enough
a prenup is not really gonna work i mean
uh but generally speaking if you don't
have kids she should stay stay employed
and not quit her job um this is like a
frame thing that we can talk about
another time but
you get the point uh children forward
the idea captured the minds of many
progressives including the british
philosopher bertrand russell and the
denver judge and social reformer ben b
lindsay who embraced the new economic
and cultural freedoms of the
post-victorian era
while ellis gave this type of temporary
marriage a name others had been talking
about similar unions years before
including the german poet johann von
goethe
pronouncing that wrong obviously who
entertained the idea of his elective
affinities in 1809 and the american
paleontologist edie cope who wrote his
book the marriage problem in 1888
in 1888 they're writing books about
marriage problems that they like could
you imagine taking this dude from 1888
put them in a time machine and bring him
over here today and let him see what
marriages look like today
just just marinate on that for a second
and you know he's written a book in 1888
called the marriage problem i wonder
what problems he was talking about at
that time
that marriages should start with a
five-year contract sure five year lease
same thing right uh that either spouse
could end or renew with a further 10 to
15-year contract and if all still went
after that a permanent contract
in 19
1888 they're dealing with basically car
leases in in marriages back then that's
interesting uh in 1966 the american
anthropologist margaret mead suggested a
two-step version of marriage an
individual commitment that would fit
college students of limited means and
could easily be dissolved or else
converted into a parental commitment if
they are ready and willing to take on
the obligations of children 1971 the
maryland legislator lena king lee
proposed a marriage contractual
renewable bill so couples could
null or renew their marriage every three
years
that's an interesting concept in 20 or
sorry 2007 a german legislator proposed
a seven-year contract in 2010 a women's
group in the philippines proposed a
10-year marital contract that's
interesting because philippines is a
very conventional religious country
um they don't generally believe in
divorce if i'm not mistaken of the
filipinos that i know and in 2011 mexico
city legislators suggested reform to the
civil code that would allow couples to
decide on the length of the marital
commitment with a minimum of two years
well it gives you a chance to uh
you know take it for a trial run i guess
if if that's what you're looking at
anyway clearly lifelong marriages was
due for an overhaul despite i don't
think marriages were lifelong
only until recent history there's a book
by stephanie koontz a history of
marriage i've mentioned it before and i
reference it in my book as well
and uh marriage has never been about
love or any of those things it's always
been about the acquisition of in-laws
and there was divorces
for hundreds of years or you know
whatever you would have called them
hundreds of thousands of years whether
it's the idea of a divorce as it's known
today but
unions would break up often um and they
would have to deal with the assets the
kids and you know stuff like that more
often not um the father actually uh
maintained custody of the children
especially when they were a little bit
older
um 100 of the time and a lot of these
moms had to go back to their you know
their family or they ended up working in
a brothel or something like that
despite all the talk however no laws
were ever passed and the idea of
renewable marriages remained just that
an idea but temporary merit see i don't
think that this would ever become
anything and i'll tell you why
because we live in a female first
primary society and everything in law
in society is is is built around the
notion that we have to protect you know
women like men are disposable men are
the disposable sex women are the
protected sex
so the reason why we've got to where we
are today where we have uh family
legislation in almost all western
countries uh that is not particularly
friendly to
men or fathers especially fathers more
so than just men
um is to protect the female first
primary social order even though you
know it shouldn't need any said
protecting because you know women's so
strong and independent today right
anyway um but temporary marriages have
been actually
actually been successful practice for
centuries among peru oh here we go
peruvian indians in the andes in 15th
century indonesia and ancient japan were
the islamic world and the islamic world
and elsewhere and it appears that we
might be ready to put them in practice
again all right let's see what they want
to say here
in a recent survey many millennials
indicated they'd be open to a beta
marriage in which couples i don't think
that means like alpha or beta it's like
a trial in which couples would commit to
each other for a certain number of years
two years seem to be the right amount
after which they would renew renegotiate
or split as jessica bennett wrote in
time magazine last year while it wasn't
a scientific survey it points to a
willingness to see marriages as
something other than until death which
in fact it is not in 2013 40 of
newlyweds had been married at least once
before
i can't believe people do this like two
three times around it's it's comical
because when you look at the stats
first time marriage is 50 failure rate
of the ones that stay together uh only
13
in total indicate that they're still in
love and 3 i believe it is indicate that
they're still in a state of bliss
so the vast majority of those that stay
married are unhappily married probably
because they don't have better options
or they're too gross or they don't have
the money to split up or i don't know
they're too plugged in or whatever it
happens to be and then after that if
they go and get remarried every time you
get remarried after that the percentage
the the the chances of a divorce
increase dramatically i think first time
it's 50
second time is 70
third time is definitely more than 70 i
think it's 80 something percent
but anyway people are going back and
forth so 40 percent of newlyweds had
never been married or sorry had been
married at least once before according
to the us
think tank the pew research center since
ten percent of first marriages don't
even make it past five years ten percent
of first don't even make it past well i
wasn't on ten percent
a renewable marriage contract makes more
sense than ever our current contract
until death might have worked when
people didn't live all that long
according to american sociologists and
author stephanie coons there she is
great by the way uh marriage of history
is what the title of the book is the
average marriage and colonial times
lasted under 12 years
um what was colonial times let me just
uh do a quick google search on what era
that was
colonial times colonial times
night prior to 1972 that's not that yeah
early 17th century
during the 17th and 18th century okay so
that's what that was
temporary let's go back here to stream
until death colonial times under 12
years so 12 years was a typical marriage
length
about 300 years ago
or when many women died in childbirth
freeing men to marry multiple times
which they did of course
uh and when men of means needed women to
cook clean and caretake and women needed
men for financial security yeah so this
is an interesting point because
this was a time you know when men of
means of if you had financial resources
you would often have
um you know your woman stay home cook
clean and care take you basically be a
homemaker which
you know like interestingly is
um
like the toxic feminists hate that like
why do anything for the express
pressure of men
when you don't need no man and you
should just go out and get a career in a
degree and don't have kids and sort of
stuff like that that's why we've got a
bit of a messy world today because of
that notion and in some cases men of
means even had multiple women uh cook
clean and caretake for the children in
the household while men
provided financial security
the interesting thing is is
women don't need no man today but
everything in family law is written in
such a way that it ensures her financial
security today still so she has freedom
but still has the benefits of financial
security from the dude
but that isn't why we marry nowadays
still we congratulate couples on their
anniversaries and get nostalgic as the
years add up 15 25 50 75
years and as the years of wedding bliss
not always many long-term marriages are
loveless and sexless as i pointed out
earlier
again what was it uh 13 are in a state
of where they still love each other
and uh only three percent are in a state
of bliss and like the whole notion of a
of a wedding of a marriage is basically
sold to people i think younger people
for sure especially if they spend a lot
of time watching disney and all the crap
that um you know the plugged in medium
wanted you to
believe in
um was that you would be in a state of
bliss just go get married you shall love
you forever she'll enthusiastically
don't want to jump your bones every day
sort of thing
uh but the reality of that is it's not
true the most popular google search for
men today is how do i get my wife here
actually let's go through that exercise
because i shared this earlier a week or
so ago
uh
how do
i get my wife oh here let me put it up
on the screen for you and to stream
let's go a little bit bigger for you
how do i get my wife okay so these are
the recommended um solutions to this
search
how do i get my wife to fall in love
with me again how do i get my wife to
love me again how do i get my wife to
lose weight how do i get my wife to be
more adventurously sexually how do i get
my wife to trust me how do i get my wife
back
[Laughter]
forgive me respect me on the house deed
the main ones seem to here let's put two
after life two
to fall in love with me again to lose
weight to be more adventurous sexually
to trust me forgive me respect me stop
snoring
[Laughter]
uh yeah they don't seem to be
particularly aligned with um the notion
of what you know we're sold you know for
marriage right anyway but that isn't why
we married nowadays uh wedding bliss not
always many long-term marriages are
loveless and sexist yeah okay well we
can see by the google searches uh what
what dudes are looking for i wonder what
women search for let me just uh
how do i get my husband here let's
reverse that how do i get my
uh
oh hang up
how do i get my husband two
and let's add the stream oh hang on
so how do i get my
husband hang up not to love me again
let's just put two how do i get my
husband to love me again talk about his
feelings
don't don't follow any of that talk
about his feelings love language
[ __ ] guys how do i get my husband to
move out how do i get my husband to help
around the house to pay attention to me
as we know you know for women attention
is the coin of the realm for them that's
what they're interested in how do i get
my husband to leave how do i get that my
husband to leave my house
i don't know but for the most part
whenever i talk to couples it always
seems like the dude is paying that pain
for the house so
here we have how do i get my husband to
leave my house
anyway how do i get my husband to
exercise fall in love with me again
there's not a lot of you know um
indications there that there's warm
fuzzy uh and it's it's it's tied into
the same problems guy had you know dudes
have
um and sometimes full of anger and
resentment but if they make it until a
spouse dies success
anyway this is almost over longevity
alone shouldn't be the marker of a happy
healthy marriage rather than staying in
marriages until death renewable
marriages should allow partners to tweak
their marriage contract accordingly or
agree could you imagine like after three
years you're like you know what i think
we want to you know tweak this
arrangement because um i'm not getting
hummers anymore and she's putting a
little bit too much weight you know then
she comes at you with uh oh he needs to
pay for this or he needs to do more of
this around the house or something like
that
you know then you're getting down to the
point of negotiating desire which only
leads to resentment down the road
turns into a train wreck
um
tweak their marital contracts or agree
that it's beyond tweaking and end it
without a shock or drama of a
contentious divorce or lingering doubts
about what went wrong and as the late
nobel prize winning economist gary s
becker noted if every couple had to
personalize their marital contract based
on what they consider important there
would be no more societal stigma of
judgment over what is essentially
private decisions
if society is truly concerned about the
climate in marriage perhaps it's time to
rethink until death i don't it's not to
rethink see i'll tell you what the
solution is here guys it's not to
rethink until death or you know putting
in terms that would just give a guy an
out
in case things go sideways in case
you know
she blimps up and you know packs on
maximum density um in case she turns
into
a psychopath and you can't untie the
knot unless you go through all the
you're going to jump through all the
hoops to make that sort of thing happen
like it would have some benefit to men
you know generally speaking but
honestly if you want to see a increase
or an incline in marriages
have women you know return to more
feminine roles men you know return to
more masculine roles stop trying to
feminize men stop trying to masculinize
women
uh men leave men have authority in the
household that's another big part too is
like for hundreds of well
since the dawn of time basically when
men and women were getting together and
you know having kids informing families
and doing all this stuff
was men were always at the head of the
household they always had the authority
they had responsibility to the family to
protect provide feed you know fight off
the saber-tooth tigers and tigers and
all that stuff but along with those
responsibilities came the authority to
make decisions and to make calls
today men don't have authority anymore
so
you want to see an improvement in
marriage rates and uh
you know like anything that ties into
that
stop the pacification of the west is
what it boils down to but nobody wants
to hear that it's like oh that's
misogyny that's you're just you just
want to go back in a time machine i
don't care you know you could do
whatever you want it doesn't it really
doesn't affect me because i've
structured my life in such a way that
i avoid these nightmares and you know
you can too i mean i talk a lot about
that in my book obviously and a lot of
these other podcast episodes but you get
the point anyway
and grooms to be truly want to be happy
then it's time for them take
responsibility for defining their goals
and expectations in a renewable contract
and stating out loud on paper i choose
you again as often as they mean it how
about how about all the ladies get
together and take off their pink [ __ ]
hats and go down to parliament hill
and uh start marching on bureaucrats and
policymakers and letting them know that
uh the guys that they love that they
want to be with that they want to have
their babies are not marrying them
because of hostile family laws and to at
least you know at least start with
making family law more balanced
uh looks like vicki larson is the author
of this one hey guys i really hope that
you enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you